The highest derivative here is the first one.
The highest derivative here is the second one.
And here it's the first one again.
So that's the order -- 1, 2 and 1.
The first one isn't a system. It's just a single equation.
The second one either.
The third one is a system -- two equations.
The first one is explicit.
The highest derivative appears on one side alone and nowhere else.
This one is not explicit.
The highest derivative is hidden inside the sine.
Same here. The highest derivative --
one of the two highest derivatives, I should be saying --
is hidden, so this one is not explicit either.
This one is linear.
In this case, we have the sine of the function we're looking for.
This is not linear.
And in this case we have the square of the function we're looking for,
which, again, is not linear.